okay
so for tonight i am very pleased to
introduce our speaker
devin conathan devin is currently a
senior data scientist
on the machine learning research team at
american family insurance
in his current role he enjoys developing
full-stack solutions
that leverage state-of-the-art machine
learning research
his recent work mainly involves natural
language processing
information retrieval knowledge graphs
and knowledge graph embeddings
feel free to ask questions in the chat
box throughout i'll read them to devin
at the end
of the presentation in roughly the order
that they were asked
i'll pass it to you now devin oh great
great uh thank you for the introduction
and uh thanks
uh for all the uh people for attending
this
uh this talk virtually so um
yeah so i'm gonna be talking about uh
tools and techniques for bringing
machine learning research to production
um and so you know that's uh probably
could have
come up with a more succinct title for
that um but
um yeah that's the uh that's the general
idea
um and um yeah so uh
rebecca and i were talking you know i
just i'm on this machine learning
research team
and um so the way it generally works is
our we kind of split our time 50 50 from
in this research world
and which is more kind of like academic
in nature and we try to publish
papers and then more kind of like maybe
traditional
data science and machine learning work
where we
try to develop solutions um for or
develop
solutions and develop products for the
for our business
um and you know in the best case
scenario we get to take the ideas that
we research and
bring them uh over to these uh uh
these solutions um and uh it turns out
that like that's a really hard
kind of thing there's a really hard
problem to solve of uh how do you bring
research to production um so i deal with
this problem a lot
and um and uh i
like to think i have some nice uh tools
and techniques for it and i
like uh giving this sort of talk so um
so yeah that's what i'm gonna talk about
today
um so just a high level overview of what
um we're talking about oh
meant to get rid of that here but um so
um
why this talk i talked a little bit
about this you know this is just a
really hard problem
um um and then i'm gonna talk about kind
of like
big picture lessons from software
engineering you know like ideas that we
can borrow from software engineering to
help uh make this problem easier
um specifically i like to talk about uh
we spent some time talking about the
python packaging system which i think is
a very powerful tool that um
all data scientists machine learning
engineers
uh should become very familiar with um
i hear like a lot of people passing like
talk
mentioned in passing oh you should learn
how to package your code but they don't
necessarily actually talk about what
that means and
the tools that are available so i like
to spend a little bit of time on that
um and then i'm actually just going to
have like a demo
research project and walk through and
kind of give you an overview so
i've given a couple of versions of this
talk before and
some of those um usually i just kind of
like um
pitch all these ideas and and but for
this project i wanted to do something a
little different or this this talk i
wanted to
do something a little different and
actually just kind of put my money where
my mouth is
and do a fun side research project and
apply these techniques to do
to that and i think it worked out pretty
well so hopefully
you uh get something out of that um
so a little bit about me um so rebecca
gave a little bit of a
introduction about my work um but just
more about about a little bit about my
background
so currently i live and work in madison
wisconsin which is where
american family is uh headquartered in
i grew up in hudson valley new york i
went to school in ithaca new york
um i also i did live in chicago for a
few years and my wife
uh went to the university of champaign
urbana so i lived in
urbana for a few years um undergrad
i studied math and philosophy and i
studied machine learning as a grad
student
and these last two points you know so i
worked various odd jobs between
undergrad and grad
and um i also like to imagine that you
know i didn't learn to code until grad
school
so you know i did study math as an
undergrad but you don't learn
coding as a math major you've learned
really your
theoretical abstract stuff um so i like
to just
mention these last two points whenever i
get a chance at talks like these
because um you know if you're
sort of outside this field it can be a
little a little intimidating to break
into it
um and and you know as someone who like
was working various like
customer service and food industry jobs
i thought
i would never be able to get like a
technical job like this
um and i sort of just you know fit the
bullet went to grad school
and kind of taught myself how to code
and here i am
um and so you know i wish i had someone
like me
telling me hey just do it so if you're
not sure and you're intimidated
like everyone's intimidated just do it
go for it and then uh don't be scared
um so um yeah so moving on to like why
is um this kind of like research
uh two production um kind of pipeline
so hard um and i think uh one of the key
things is that um you know like research
uh and software engineering kind of
fundamentally
are very almost like opposite things so
like research
on one hand is that it's very personal
it means something different to everyone
uh it's ephemeral you know a project
you're working on today
might um might you know disappear in a
few days or you're probably gonna move
on to something else
um it's dynamic so it's changing it's
vague um
by vague i mean like success is hard to
define it's not even clear like what is
successful in unsuccessful research um
where software engineering is like
mostly the opposite of all these things
it's the opposite of personal it's
designed to be
you know to work the agnostic as the to
the person who's running it
um it's the you know it's designed to
stick around for years if not decades
it's designed to always be the same and
success is very easy to define like
does your code run and does it do what
it's supposed to do um
and so there's a tension between these
two kind of like uh
uh you know fields um
and so uh like blindly taking like
software engineering techniques and just
saying like
you know apply them to research doesn't
work um we're dealing with a lot of that
um like trying to take like scrum and
agile techniques and applying them to
research and it doesn't
the ideas don't necessarily translate um
but still i think you know at a high
level there are lessons
that you can borrow from software
engineering to make research
um more streamlined and especially to
bring
bring your research projects to uh
production and turn them into software
um and so you know just at a very high
level um
you're going to do a deep dive into some
of this stuff um
these are the things like i like to
highlight um data structures are key
so there's a reason in you know computer
science 101
um you just start with data structures
um because they're kind of
essential i mean usually usually in the
you know software engineering and
computer science world data structures
is taught
from the perspective of like the
algorithm and the computer and how to
you know make the algorithm uh as fast
as possible
um or as scalable as possible um
and usually in the kind of like in the
data science world it's
kind of more you know data structures
are there to make your code
uh easier to read by humans
and um so i think that you know maybe
they're
obviously you know you're also thinking
about data structures from a performance
point of view
but having the right data structures is
kind of key to making your
code readable both readable and
extensible
um if you want to kind of like bring you
know bring more eye
research ideas into into your software
um consistency and reproducibility is
obviously very important in software
engineering you
want your code to kind of run day in and
day out and do the same thing over and
over again
um this is also a big kind of like
problem in research especially machine
learning where there's a lot of
randomness
so there are basically
ideas from software engineering that we
can borrow
um to kind of make your code uh make
your experiments
um more consistent um and more
reproducible um this next point
uh i'm gonna spend a lot of time talking
about but packaging your code um so the
idea of
um you know thinking about your
kind of research project is something
you can package and ship off to
some something and have it be able to
run on someone else's computer
these are things that are important to
think of and there's a lot of
you know you know basically this is kind
of the foundation of software
engineering is like
building these packages that can then be
shipped to other computers so
there's a lot of tools and techniques
that we can that we can take from that
um i feel like every talk kind of like
this uh talks about tests
um and this this is another area of what
where those is one of these tensions
um because testing to a data scientist
means something very different than
testing to a software engineer
um so like data scientist tests usually
mean
uh what's your accuracy on your test set
where a software engineer is like
you know do all your unit tests which
test the individual functionality of
all your functions um do those all do
the right thing
so i think there's a middle ground
between these two um
and i'm going to get to it a little bit
later when i kind of do the review of my
project
and i think i have like a pretty
sensible at least like place to start
um where you have some tests but you
don't go crazy and test every little
thing
because that's one of the problems of
kind of unit test
research is the research is always
changing and you don't want to have to
you know spend all your time writing
your tests only to have to rewrite them
the next day
um and then lastly there's like uh this
field of
continuous integration continuous
deployment which i think is like
especially a nice fit for research
um because the idea is you know research
is always changing
and uh and dynamic and continuous
integration continuous deployment lets
us you know incorporate those ideas
um from research into our product as
quickly as possible
and um the tooling around this um is
getting like
better and better and cheaper uh every
day in fact if you have
a github account you can start playing
around with ci
cd today for free um and i did that for
this project so i'll show you how to do
that
it's pretty cool if you haven't dipped
your toes in this waters
it's a good time to do that um
so yeah so i wanted to talk about like
python packaging 101
um because i think this is you know this
is really essential and so
you know just a just mention here like i
think throughout
this like i kind of try to include a
little bit for everyone so there's some
like i start out like really basic
but i get pretty complex and there's a
lot of parts moving parts
uh going forward so i hope there's a
little bit of everything for everyone
so um yeah so i wanted to start out just
really basic
packaging 101 and i wanted to establish
some terminology because i hear these
words
and phrases kind of used interchangeably
a lot
it's important to make sure we're all on
the same page so if you have
main.py um that is what i call a script
and you know that's just a python file
that has a bunch of code and you're
supposed to run it
and it does something maybe you print
something in a terminal terminal or
creates a file or whatever
but it's not meant to be like part of a
larger system
maybe it uses a larger system but it's
just kind of like a standalone thing
uh contrast that to uh like maybe
utils.py
which is a module so you're not supposed
to like run utils.py it just contains a
bunch of functions
um that's maybe main.py uses some of the
functions that are in utils
and so you can sort of you can import
stuff from from utils
um and the name module comes from the
fact that it's sort of like it's modular
you can kind of like slot it
into different places um and then
what a package is in the python sense is
simply a
folder that contains a bunch of modules
and so here i've got a package called
stuff and there is a
special module uh called dunderinit.py
and that just tells python hey this
folder is actually a package
you can import it um
and and so it lets you kind of like
organize like uh
you know a collection of modules that
may be a part of
some one particular system into uh into
one package
um and then a library is kind of the
next step up it's just a collection of
packages
um the standard python standard library
and packages um can com
can contain like other packages or sub
packages
so you know at what point does a package
become a library
um i don't know um but so i i think it's
fairly okay to use package and library
interchangeably
um as long as the you know it's a big
enough package i guess um
but yeah so um just wanted to talk about
um
some uh terminology before we go into it
so
um now i just wanted to do some kind of
like fun with the terminal
uh where i talk about python's packaging
system so
i've got an empty directory here with a
fresh virtual environment a scratch
environment
and so i'm going to uh make a package
i'm just going to call it some package
and i'm going to create that dunder emit
uh file um and this lets me like uh
let's let let's uh add something to that
under init and say hello equals
world and now so i can
open up a python terminal and i can
import some pack some package
um oops this is where the live coding
part is not
a good idea and i can so call some
package.hello
and get world um
uh and this i'm able to import it
because it's sort of like in my current
directory so it's in my path
um but maybe you want to like turn this
into a package that you can ship off
um and the way python does that is you
create
a script called setup.py
and in setup.py you uh
you import a function from this package
in the standard library called setup
tools
you call this import this setup function
and then i'm also going to import this
useful function called find packages
and so you call the setup function and
there's a few you know
lots of arguments you can pass the setup
function but the the
essential ones you'll need are name
some package and so this is like the
name of your package so if you were to
publish this to pie pie
um and then like make it so other people
could tip pip install your package they
would
tip and solve what the name is here so
clip install
some package so this would have to be
unique
version you probably want to include a
version
because versioning your package is
important
and and then finally you just want to
say
list the packages you want to include in
um in this
package or library you're distributing
and
that's where this find packages um
function uh comes in handy so this is
would just be a list
that contains say that folder some
package
um this find packages uh function
just like find set automatically for me
um
and so no now if i call if i run
setup.ui
i mean i could just run it and it will
say uh no command slide
um if you run python setup.ui
install um it actually just installed my
package
into my virtual environment um so you
can see it created a bunch of folders uh
uh a build in a disk um but you know so
i can like
let's say i go into um go into here
um and there's some stuff in here but i
just want to go in here to
demonstrate that i can import some
package
um and you can look at it and you can
see it's no longer the thing that's
in that scratch enviro scratch folder i
was looking at
actually in my virtual environment um
and and i can call that and take a look
at that
um so that's that's kind of like the the
bare bones basic of what you can do so
um let's uninstall um
uninstall um
[Music]
there we go oh forgot another end um
so um
so okay so that's that's the the
simplest way to install
something um so let's say i don't want
to install it i just want to like kind
of
create a package that i want to give to
other people
um so i'm just going to delete these
disks and build
uh folders because i want to talk about
what they actually are so um if you
run um uh setup.ui um
there's a couple different ways to
create packages the
the simplest is called an sdist or a
source distribution
um and what this does uh
if i go it created set that dist folder
and if i go in there
i created this uh archive um
uh and i can uh untar that
um well one i can pip and solve this so
that's
that's cool um um
and then uh but i kind of wanted to just
uh let's see
um and you can see um all that did was
take the the setup.py and my package and
put it into this archive along with a
bunch of other metadata
um so that's all the source disk is
is a you know you're just distributing
the source of your package
um so um another
uh kind of like a a better way of
distributing your package
is a build distribution
and there's a couple different ways of
sort of packaging a build distribution
the standard way of doing that today
is a wheel um and that's
sort of the recommended way um and so
what this does
um in this this folder creates this dot
wheel file
and again this is something i can tip
install um
directly it's going to complain that i
already have the package installed
um but what this this is just a zip file
um and if i look in that so this is all
that's in the zip file
and kind of most importantly you'll
notice the setup.py
is no is not in this file it just
contains
you know it contains some metadata and
it contains
the um the setup the just the package
and the package code in this case just
this one file
um so that's a key distinction between
the build distribution and the source
distribution
and obviously this doesn't really matter
for such a small package like this
but if you take a large package like
tensorflow or
pi torch um and you try to do the source
distribution of it and install that on
your machine
um so one it's gonna be a pain in the
butt because you have to
have all these requirements um to even
like
install like run the setup.py and
compile all the files because there's a
bunch of c code in those
packages um and it's going to take like
uh maybe an hour on your machine if you
need to compile code
whereas a build distribution you compile
it ahead of time
and then you take the output of what
gets compiled and distribute that
um and so um what when you
like when i run the pip install uh of
this wheel file
literally all it does is unpack you know
unzip the file
and copy the files into the virtual
environment versus
the source distribution when you install
it it actually kind of
runs that setup.py so that's a pretty
key distinction
important to understand the difference
there um but the
the takeaway is you know if you want to
do some like
weird stuff with the setup.py file you
might want to do the source distribution
um but um the most kind of like portable
and easy way
uh and kind of a small uh most efficient
way to distribute packages is with the
wheel because installing them is
literally just
copying some files and that's why you
can tip install
torch uh pie torch or tensorflow on your
machine and it just takes
uh a few seconds um and
um yeah so that's what i wanted to um
talk about uh mostly with that
um there's a bunch of other stuff you
can do with the
setup.py file um and i'll um
i think i'll just wait until i go
through my demo
project to um to go through that um so
i'm gonna go back to my slides now
um so yeah so now i wanted to move on
just uh you know the part
like i said where i put my money where
my mouth is and just
do a i did a demo research project and i
just want to kind of walk through
that um and so basically
uh so rebecca mentioned in the intro
my kind of research at work is kind of
primarily in the
fields of like natural language
processing and information retrieval um
so i wanted to take the stuff that i do
for work and apply them to something fun
and that's what i did here so just
this is going to be a bunch of crash
courses about what all these things mean
so again this is just to give you the
bare minimum so that you understand a
little bit about what's going on
um and so hopefully uh you know some of
you are somewhat familiar
and hopefully there's some something new
for everyone so
um information retrieval uh is pretty
straightforward is
literally retrieving information um and
are kind of quintessential this is a
very like meta explanation of what uh
information retrieval is uh but the you
know the quintessential
uh information retrieval uh solution
is google and so the idea is an
information retrieval you have
a query and you've got a corpus in this
case
in google case report your corpus is all
of the internet
and you want to find the
appropriate you know document web page
resource or whatever that's in your
corpus
that best kind of answers the query
um in this case the wikipedia page on
information retrieval is the best answer
uh to this question
and as you can see there's a pretty good
answer to information retrieval
um which is maybe slightly more
technical than the one i gave
or or maybe not um
so that's what i want to talk about
there um so um
next i'm going to talk about
transformers which is um
a recent kind of it's like basically the
state-of-the-art
natural language processing uh model
today
um and um introduced just a few years
ago but it's uh you know
quickly becoming the standard for doing
anything interesting in this
in this field um and
i could spend a whole hour talking about
transformers um
but i'm not so but what you need to
know for the purposes of this project is
that transformers are a machine learning
model that
takes as an input a string or a text um
in outputs a vector and so in this case
i have the text what is the transformer
and
outputs the vector 2 4. um
in reality the dimension is much larger
than 2
you know hundreds of dimensions but
obviously that's pretty hard to
visualize and so lastly i want to give
you a magic to gather in crash course
and so this is one of my hobbies
and you know if there are people into
magic here
i'd love to talk about it maybe offline
so um
but uh the idea is so magic the
gathering is a trading card game
um and um you have cards that look like
this
um and the object of the game is
to uh you have like one versus one and
you're trying to
do damage to the opponent and all these
cards represent spells that you know
interact with the game or interact with
the players in various ways
an important point here is that each
card
has a name in this case lightning bolt
and
each card has some rules text that
says what the card does in this case
lightning bolt deals three damage to
target creature or player
um so putting it all together um
you know what am i proposing as a
research project here
um you know given you know so given a
query use transformers to find all
similar cards to that query um
so um you know uh in if you put in the
query
uh lightning bolt you might get you know
you would find the card's lightning bolt
but you would might also find the card
feedback bolt lightning strike precision
bolt um
and you know you can imagine the naive
thing to do would just be like find all
the cards that have the word lightning
and have the word bolts in them and
return those
um but if we use transformers in their
ability to kind of interpret things as
vectors
um we can you know uh think about like
what are the semantics of the word
lightning bolt and what are the
semantics of the rules text uh
you know do three damage to target uh
creature or player
and maybe we can find cards that do
similar stuff
to these cards but don't share the same
exact words
um so this is like a common trend um to
just try to take these like more natural
language understanding type models and
apply them to the this field
um so what does it all look like
as you know kind of more concrete
experiment um
so another reason um i wanted to
uh i chose magic the gathering as a sort
of like data set uh if you will is
it's really easy to get you know all to
download a json file
all the magic gathering cards in
existence so um
that was really easy to get and so you
can process that
and get these name text pairs and the
idea um
uh in the information retrieval sense
we're going to try to
er we're going to we get we can treat
the
name as like our query and the text the
rules text of the card as our cop
like our true context like the best
context that matches that query
um and so that way we get you know each
card becomes
a training example for our model so we
get
basically like a bunch of you know
there's tens of thousands of cards in
existence so we get a bunch of like free
training data for this problem so
it's actually like a fun problem to work
on
um high level overview of the model um
so we have two transformers here
one is going to turn the name into a
vector
the name of a card into a vector one is
going to turn the rules text of a card
into the vector
um and then we look at the dot
product similarity of those vectors and
if it's a high similarity
we say uh yes this is a good this card
is a good match for this uh
for this name return it um and otherwise
don't
um and then in terms of kind of like a
research uh
you know question um with this with
these transformers there's a lot of
different architectures and hyper
parameters
um and so we want to say you know
try out a bunch of different different
of these um so you know
you take the data and each kind of
version of this model
is an experiment uh we run a bunch of
experiments and we take the the best
uh experiment and we can can we deploy
that as a web app that
anyone can use in in search search for
cards um
so um yeah so now we're going to just
move on to
uh this project and kind of walk through
it so um
i spent the pretty much just spent a
weekend working on this project um
and i'm just gonna um and this is on
github so i i
i'll share the link i guess when after
the talk so you can
explore it on your own um but
um yeah let's um uh i'll kind of like
walk through it um
let me do a quick time check so we've
got about 20
minutes or so so i can give a whirlwind
tour there's a lot going on here
um so um again i hope there's a little
bit of
interesting stuff for everyone um but
yeah let's talk about the setup.ui since
we were just talking about that
um so this is maybe like what a more um
a more interesting setup.ui
um looks like um maybe where you're more
used to so the name we saw the name we
still have a version
um here i'm importing the version from
inside the package
um and then uh we have
um you know the packages um so install
requires this is
you know you're probably familiar with
what this does
is you know in order to run this package
um
you need a bunch of other libraries like
pytorch and transformers and et cetera
and so this when you install the package
it installs all these
extras require is another thing so
maybe you've seen so basically what this
means if i do pip install
mcg search and then do train in brackets
it will install these packages as well
as these packages
and so basically this is just saying you
know in order to train the model
you need to install these extra packages
so install that version
um console scripts is
a are sort of entry points console
scripts
is a interesting basically that's what
this defines lets you define a bunch of
commands that will get added to your
path
when you install the package and use
basically says
uh the ntg search command will run the
main function
of some module inside my library
so um you know so if i open up a turbo
i've got this package installed in this
environment
if i run mtg search it actually um
runs a file that's in here um and so
that's
a nice way to build a command line
interface to your um
to your to your package um and then this
is kind of maybe the most unconventional
um
aspect of this um but i think it's
really important especially for
machine learning research projects like
this
um so package data so
find packages or packages is what
kind of like looks through all the
python code and ads automatically
includes all the python code as part of
your
package distribution but what package
data does
is find it lets you define non-python
files to also include with the package
so in this case most importantly we're
going to uh
include the model itself when we
distribute our package
um and so um that's a kind of an
important thing
it's supposed to like saying like oh in
order to get my model you need to
or in order to run my model you need to
clone my repo and follow these steps to
get the model and whatever no
it's like no we're we're distributing a
like fully
encapsulated working version of this you
know
as a product and saying you know when
you pip install this thing
you can run all the functions uh that i
uh
include with it including um uh the ones
that
that need the model um so um that's an
important thing uh
aspect of it um and um
[Music]
um uh and i'll also point out that uh i
included this at the beginning of the
setup.py and basically
um this just uh you know we talked a
little bit about
like uh unit tests um and i would
consider this maybe like a
a basic unit test of like this basically
what this says
is don't build the package unless the
model
exists um and you know you could build a
development version of the package
without the model um but um
uh yeah so basically like you're at this
point like you're guaranteed if you're
distributing the package that it's going
to include the model um
so yeah so that's all i wanted to talk
about the setup.py
um so i'm going to kind of just give a
quick overview of some of the
important modules and packages inside
my package um so almost all of my
machine learning research projects look
somewhat like this
so i always include a constant stop py
which
defines you know all my paths my data
files and directories and
stuff that you know it's not going to
change really um
if there's like a database involved
they'll include like you know where the
database is
and this um so yes so
i highly recommend a constant py file to
find that sort of stuff
um let's talk about data so that's
always where i start
um and i usually define
you know my data looks like this if i
have like various data sets i'll also
have like a data sets
uh folder um but i always define a data
classes
folder or a sorry a module
and this is where i define all the data
structures that um
you know kind of my model interacts with
um at various level of pre-processing so
like you know
our kind of more raw data is just like
what is a card
um and then all the way down to like
what is a training batch
um and so you'll notice that all these
are
are these uh data classes which is a
built-in
um a utility class in the python
standard library i highly recommend
that you use them um because this kind
of gets that that um
you know makes your code you know the
data classes are
not for computers they're for people um
so you know it's really easy to look at
this class and like okay what is this
class oh it is a
a class that sort of data and the schema
looks like this
and it's got two properties name and
text that are string so
it's like just by looking at i don't
even need any um
you know documentation or doctrine or
anything like you can just look at this
and say okay i know what this thing did
i know what this thing is
um and similar for for
the rest of the things um and yeah then
i'll talk
about data modules um
so i use pi torch this the name of this
comes from
pytorch lightning which defines this
concept of a lightning data module
so pi torch lightning is a super helpful
package or library for training high
torch models
highly recommend it if you are if you
use torch to train your
models and basically um this
just defines kind of like the logic it
encapsulates all the logic about
um taking your raw data and splitting it
into trained pests and valves splits
and um uh pre-processing the data
and getting your data loaders kind of
like puts that's all a nice
one nice little um uh helper class um
so um yeah so that's one all i wanted to
talk about uh
data um so next is models
in a typical project i might have like
many different
folders with different kinds of models
here um
for this project i just had time to try
out one model um
this transformer model
but similar here i love data classes
and what is a model uh what is a machine
learning model other than
basically a function that takes an input
and returns an output
and so really easy to define um
those here um uh and then
um uh pi torch lightning also has this
it defines a lightning module which is
essentially a
torch uh you know a pie torch model um
but it it takes care of a lot of the
kind of
boilerplate code so you don't you know
you basically you get to write
the stuff that you're interested in and
don't have to deal with all the
sort of training logic and all that um
so i'm going to gloss over all the most
of the details there but basically uh
that's what's just a class that defines
the model and defines all your
kind of um training sets um
and important things i like to highlight
here um that you get
basically for free with pi torch
lightning um
so one um so i defined this main
uh main um python file and basically you
know this gets
executed so uh this transformer.py
is also a script and
with pi torch um or padrech lightning
they have a way of you know
automatically inserting a bunch of
all the basically the keyword arguments
that you could pass to a trainer
um as um as an argument parser um
and so you can just pass them as flags
to your command line
app um so that's cool you got to get a
bunch of stuff for free there
um uh then um
uh this model checkpoint um uh callback
uh will automatically save the model for
me um so that's cool
i don't have to worry about that um and
then
[Music]
for this project i'm using uh comet
called combat.ml or comet
ml it is a
model uh sort of experiment tracking
software
there's a bunch of kind of variations of
this uh weights and biases
ml flow neptune ai um
pick one of those and use it it's super
helpful uh
for projects like this
and basically you know this um
uh every time i train a model uh it uh
logs all the data uh uh you know all the
hyper parameters and all the kind of
results
um to this uh to this like web app
um and i can it stores that information
for you
um and kind of uh uh most importantly
well let's say
you know so it gives you kind of like an
overview of like
how long it took to train each model and
you can kind of quickly see oh
you know i trained a few versions of
this model but this this is the only one
that did any good it got 70
test accuracy so that's what i want um
and um and most importantly you can kind
of view the the training
uh curves and you can see okay it seems
like the model converged
um and then uh most importantly it gives
you this experiment key this is like a
unique identifier for this
version of training the model and the
way i set this up is the model
checkpoint
automatically saves the
saves the model in the models directory
with that key as the folder so if i go
into this
models directory here um i have um you
know
uh two versions of the model
um that i trained and uh basically the
you know the so this way i can kind of
go through all the
all the experiments find the one where
that i want to keep and then the way
i've set it up
is that in this check checkpoint.py file
i define the checkpoint
and i just have to put that model key
inside this checkpoint
and then this checkpoint uh
variable is what defines what version of
the model gets packaged when i build the
package
so putting it all together basically you
know you just have to
um look at your experiments find the
experiment
of the best performing model and then
put it
its experiment key here and then when
you build your package that's the model
version of the model that's built with
your package so
super nice uh workflow there for
managing
uh lots of different experiments um
and then finally uh i wanted to talk
about the api
so like everything we've talked about so
far is more on like the
model development side of things um but
at some point you want
your um you want to like uh deploy or
share your model
um and that's where the api comes in the
in in into the api is like the
application programming interface but
it's like basically like makes you
think about like okay how does the
outside world going to interact with my
model
and so i usually define an api folder
and in particular
i'll define you know maybe i'll define a
web app which will serve
an endpoint of how to run the model
a command line which will uh let me
interact with the model and the command
line
but kind of common to both of those is
this um
main api um and kind of defining this
this file just like really makes you
think about like okay what
you know what are the essential things
that the outside world is going to want
to do with my model
you know kind of fundamentally we're
going to want to search
and you know in order to search what do
you need to do you need to be able to
create an index you need to be able to
load
the query encoder you need to the query
encoder is the
you know card name encoder in this case
in the context encoder or the rules text
encoder in this case
um so you need to build load your models
um and you need to
search for them and and that brings me
to the test so obviously like
oh there are like a lot of stuff going
on and all these things and you can
write tests for
every little part of it and maybe if you
have a lot of like data pre-processing
logic um you probably want to unit test
that uh
to in some sense because you know it
would suck to
um you know get very far along in this
process and then find out you have a bug
in your data preprocessing
but at a bare minimum you want to test
your api
and what i mean here is basically kind
of like everything
in the um in this main.py
gets a test in my test api folder so
can you load the can you load the query
encoder
is it you know an instance of the right
thing can i load
uh the context encoder same can i load
the index
and finally can i run a search does the
search return the right thing
you know is everything that the in their
list that the search returns
of the right type um so it's pretty kind
of like
high level tests um but as you can see
like you know
and and um there's a great uh function
or package called pi test um which will
uh
automatically run you know basically it
just looks for
uh words uh uh you know modules with the
word test in them and just runs them
um and so basically you know i can run
that
and as long as you know that test passed
sort of like i'm guaranteed that my
you know my app is going to work because
you know basically the core
functionality of how i want the outside
world to interact with my model
um uh works um so that's cool
um and um and again you know so going
back to like
you know testing can be very cumbersome
if you unit test every little thing
here i've just written you know 30 lines
of
code and you know it guarantees that my
model is going to work so
um that's great um so um you know it's
not
you know it's not a big ass to to to
write tests like this
so um that's the kind of whirlwind tour
of
um of the package itself
um and i uh finally i wanted to talk
about okay now i want to deploy this
model
um what does that look like um
um so here in the infra directory uh
just ready to keep all the uh sort of
uh configuration files to configure
infrastructure
um i don't think i have time to kind of
like dive into this but basically these
are these are all terraform
files that define that basically in a
declarative way
define a bunch of aws uh infrastructure
um and i could go in from the command
line and write
uh run some terraform commands and that
this will
uh automatically kind of create all this
aws infrastructure that will run this
code
uh for me and serve that web app that i
showed you
um but i don't wanna do that
i don't want to do that sort of manually
we want to automate that
as possible and that's where the ci cd
part comes in
and so in order to do that in github
has this new feature uh called github
actions
and what you do is um you create a
github folder and uh you know the top of
your repo and create a workflows
uh folder and that and you could create
uh you can put a bunch of yaml files
inside that
workflows folder what this is just
essentially
a configuration file that configures a
bunch of
scripts that run when i push
um to
push to the uh to the repo um and so
um uh i will just push a new version of
this
just to demonstrate what i mean there so
let's update the version
update a new version of our package
and let's see
bump version new deploy
um in the real world i might uh you know
create a pull request but obviously i'm
not
changing any features here um or
anything like that um
so um so now so if you go to the repo
um and you know so here's the repo for
this and if you go to this actions tab
um you can see um basically
this is github actions basically kind of
looking at that file
and running all the commands that are in
that file
so this takes about five minutes so
while that's going on in the background
i'll go back and kind of walk through
the file
and in what it does um
so um there's a bunch of kind of like
pre-canned actions here
um but um you know essentially we
uh it if it runs on a ubuntu
server it
installs python installs all the
dependencies
it configures aws credentials so there's
a way of kind of
storing secrets inside of github um
[Music]
because we'll need that because we want
to deploy the
uh uh deploy our stuff to aws
we download the model using i didn't
get have time to get into it but dvc is
data version control this is another
great kind of
utility to use for kind of versioning
your models
and this is basically an easy way to
like download the files
from uh download the model files
from s3 um i run the
um so if basically if any of these
commands
uh fail um the whole thing stops go you
know run the test because we don't want
to deploy a non-working version
of our package um
and we build the package um
we log into ecr and and build a docker
image and push that
and then we run the terraform commands
which stands up all the infrastructure
and then finally we test the endpoint um
so um yeah so that's that's basically a
kind of like a whirlwind tour of uh
github actions um and so yeah so this is
something if you have
um if you have a github account
you can get you can do this for free um
obviously you have to you know pay for
the aws stuff um but if you want to just
have like something that
uh runs you know installs python runs
tests and
like builds your python package um you
can do that
with you know the free github uh
account you can get i think like 2000
minutes
per month or something of a server
running
um and you know uh you know most
actions will just take a couple minutes
so pretty much as long as you don't have
like a ton of crazy projects
um we'll let you uh do whatever you want
to do um
so um another thing one last kind of
like best practice from
the sort of cicd world i'd like to
point out here um so i actually have two
branches
i have this main branch and i've got a
prod branch
um and so um
[Music]
to refresh that but the um
the uh there's a kind of a practice that
where
you know you have a branch that
corresponds to
a sort of a prod environment um
and you know and this um
and basically whenever i push a change
to the main branch
it automatically deploys and i call that
my sandbox environment
and so that way i can do like
developments and test new ideas and
maybe break stuff
and um but the uh it doesn't affect
anything that's on the prod deployment
so even though right now i'm in the
middle of deploying
um a new sandbox version of this because
i push this to main branch
i still have a working version of uh my
prod
app that i can you know go ahead and
show
you so i can do my search for lighting
bolts um
and get you know lightning bolts up top
hit but i do get
uh feedback bolt lightning strike
positionable all these like kind of
similar things
um and um yeah and
you know fun takeaway from this project
it kind of works
um and um you know so there's you know
shock it's another kind of similar card
and you get
um uh similar stuff so like i didn't
know
you know heat ray just doesn't have the
word shock in it but it does do
similar things to shock so it makes
sense that you might show up
um and then you can just obviously like
um
you know i don't know come up with like
uh ridiculous things and see
what comes out so mr sandwich the top
matching card is the cheese stand alone
makes sense why that might uh show up um
uh let's like i don't know
do that and then you get all these like
kind of like funny sounding card names
which
you know kind of like seem like they
might match with big beefy boy
um so you can have all kinds of fun with
this and um yeah
i think um you know this is something i
want to kind of
maybe keep developing because i think i
think i'm on to something
i show this to my boss who's um also
into magic
and he thinks there's there's uh
something valuable here since
because um a lot of the applications out
there for searching magic cards don't do
you know smart stuff like this um and
and they're hard to use
um so with that um you know
you can see this is still building uh
looks like it's about to deploy
um but um yeah i think i'll wrap things
up there um and uh open it up
to questions so i haven't been paying
attention to the chat or anything
um but um yeah
so um thanks for uh thanks for bearing
with me through all that so
i will uh happy to take questions
thank you so much devon i love this talk
we don't see a lot of live demos
here so cool i really appreciate it yeah
we have a handful of great questions
um the first one is from kevin oliver
who's
excited about magic okay yes
um how would you capture the mana cost
if you wanted to do that as well
would a cnn be the way or a different
kind of transformer
yeah um yeah that's actually i wanted to
if i had more time i would have come up
with like done the next iteration of the
model
um so um yeah so
basically uh you know kind of like the
baseline uh
uh uh uh thing i would do
um so that kind of gets that you know
we're changing our
um uh fundamental data structure so like
you know right now a card
is a is a um uh
it's just a name and a text but i would
you know could add some fields here you
know color
uh string and then you know
mana cost etc maybe that's a i guess
that wouldn't be in it but um
anyway you'd come up with a uh add a
bunch of new features you know there's
also like
uh card type um yeah etc
and then um and then i'd probably come
up
um so in that case we'd probably need um
a new uh data module um
um or no maybe we wouldn't uh oh yeah
because we would need a new
um a new sample um which had maybe uh a
structured field for the query
um um and then
um but then the idea is you come up with
a new model
um and i think like as a baseline i
would just
uh concatenate all that stuff as one
input so just like
um you know the rules text followed by
the
the type and the mana cost and the color
instead of just like
make it one blob of text um and seeing
and seeing
you know kind of comparing the uh test
and train
or sort of the train and val results um
with that
um but yeah to get maybe at the
the root of your question um i'm really
interested in kind of like
uh i mentioned you know some of my
background is in knowledge graphs and
knowledge graph uh embeddings and i
think there's some
ways to borrow some techniques um from
that
i think transformers have really have a
way of capturing kind of like grass
structures
um and so i would find try to find some
way of you know how can i combine
come up with embeddings of a color uh
type
um a mana cost or whatever and and
combine those
um you know come up with a new kind of
transformer architecture that is able to
combine those all into one vector but
anyway
um i could probably talk about another
hour for about
what i want to do with that but that
hopefully that's a good good answer for
now
uh i don't know how many questions there
are so um um
yeah there are uh four more but
sometimes questions keep coming so okay
we'll do a couple more um from sagar
minocha
is it standard practice to include the
model with the package
and what's the size of the model yeah
okay yeah that that's um
one thing i didn't um mention um
[Music]
part of the kind of like research
challenge i
wanted to give myself is um is uh
giving uh making it a a small enough
model both
to like make it easy to package and to
um
[Music]
make it so i could like kind of quickly
iterate on ideas and load it
um for the sake of the demo um so i am
as my like base transformer
using a um tiny bert which is just a
two layer bert that um google released
is one of their papers
um and so these models themselves
um i think they're just like 20
megabytes each
um let me see so i don't know if i can
see the file size in here but yeah i
think there was like 20 megabytes each
so um in this case these models are
pretty small
um and um um
and but yeah typically the these
transformer models are quite large
you know a couple hundred megabytes and
billions of parameters
um and i would say you know
if you're planning on kind of hosting
the package
in um you know in pi pi or
um in some sort of package um
distribution
um like github unless you actually kind
of have your own
private like uh package registry to just
just host and distribute your packages
and there is going to be a file size
limit to
that so i would say in that case it is
not
uh standard practice there um and so
if i were under those constraints i
would just you know put in some logic
to um just store a reference to the
model
and have it like download the model when
you try to run it
another option is if we are doing the
source distribution method
um i haven't actually tested this to see
if it worked but i i don't see why it
wouldn't work is to have it
as part of the setup.py and download the
model and so then you get the
you get the model when you tip install
the package
not when you you know it's not when you
deployed it or not when you
kind of build the package um so that's
another option um
but um in this case since we're not uh
uploading um the package to
um any sort of package registry we
aren't really under those constraints
um like if you just look at the uh
github um uh
this workflow um there is you know we
just build the package
um and then um and then we add it to the
docker file so it never actually kind of
like
leaves the model never kind of like
leaves this area
other than you know being on the docker
file itself um
so um you know i like to say you know
there's not
a lot of there's not there's no wrong
answers i guess there's a lot of right
ways of doing these things
as long as they kind of like fit the
constraints
um of what you're given and you know
the one constraint is you can't have
packages above 50 megabytes or whatever
the
the constraint of the package hosting
solution you have
in which case um yeah i wouldn't include
it in the package there
um but there are no rules against it um
as long as it works in your test tasks
you can do whatever you want right
great yeah i think we'll conclude with
kevin oliver has a couple more questions
okay um
is comet ml doing the hyper parameter
tuning as well um so it's not doing the
tuning
um uh it just so
in the uh
[Music]
see in the model and this
uh when you load the model here this uh
comment logger
log hyper parameters um and then i
you know i just like log this model.
config file
um and so it just logs them um so it
just kind of like gives you a snapshot
if i go here to a particular experiment
and i think there's a tab yeah tab here
for
hyper parameters that tells you you know
everything about the model so it just it
just logs them so
yeah comment doesn't do any of the
tuning
uh for that so the tuning i was all kind
of just doing
manually i was trying various um there
was
one version of the model where i was
like tweaking actually the number of
layers and stuff
um on that note
uh part of the um uh
in that case let's see um as part of the
let's see this
oh yeah here it is um part of that uh
share out that i mentioned today where
this other team shared out their
kind of methods and techniques they
showed me um this
project uh called orion um
and uh it does hyperparameter tuning for
you
and it looks pretty solid i haven't
played around with it a lot
um but the next project i take on where
i need to do
hyperparameter tuning i plan on looking
into this so
if you're looking for a hyper parameter
tuning solution
i would point you in this direction
great
uh and last question could you show the
form
the card data is in that you're training
against
uh-huh okay um so yes maybe i can like
uh
just do a quick uh form of what the
um data processing pipeline looks like
um so the raw data
um let's see um
yeah so this is the this takes in the
raw data um which is just this json file
of you know a bunch of
uh you know a bunch of dictionaries that
contain strings essentially
um and i turn it into a bunch of cards
um
and so cards look like this um they
don't have a color
but they have a name and a string um
[Music]
and then um
let's see oh yeah and then i take
let's see i think i do oh and then i
take
uh turn those into samples
and i have this uh method to turn cards
into samples
so essentially you know a sample is the
same as a card it's just that
we've renamed name and text to uh query
and string but this kind of like makes
it so like
this is you know what i would do in the
information retrieval
um sense is you know i've got a query in
the context so it sort of like
puts it into that um agnostic uh
framework um and then um
and so that that's what a sample is and
then a train sample is essentially
um is
a so when you pass it into the model
you give it a query you give it the
positive answer and then you get a
list of negative answers and so like
basically what the model is trying to do
is kind of just basically do a
multi-class classification problem um
and say like
find the correct one out of uh the uh
uh this list of negatives in the
positive um
not a batch it's just a batch of those
um and then
um turning a um
so yeah hopefully i'm not sure exactly
what which steps the question was asking
about so i'm just going to go through
all the steps um so hopefully one of
these steps answers the question but um
um so um and then we have that train
batch
um and that goes um uh
that that is what gets passed into our
model
and then i have this function that turns
a train batch
into a model and so this is what
the tokenizer tokenizes the data
and so that turns it into a batch
encoding
um and then essentially what this
is is a um there's
a few things you need to pass to a
transformer model but most importantly
it just tokenizes the text
and turns it into a series a list of
token ids and
[Music]
maybe i can and token ids is essentially
like a basically a list of integers um
and then the model
knows how to turn the integers into the
into the vectors
um so let's see um
this is where we get into the dangerous
live coding part of the talk but um
kevin wrote back and said just met the
form of the json file
oh okay yeah um
so yeah yeah so then we're talking about
the uh
the raw data um so the raw data
is um i got it from i just searched
magic together in json and there was a
pretty easy way to find it
um but um there is
um uh this data
and basically each data has every
magically gathering card set
in it and for each card set contains a
list of cards
and then each card is a json which has
all the metadata associated with that
card
um most importantly it has um
name and text which is what we're using
here
but it has all the other stuff like uh
rules uh rule or uh you know
type uh power toughness cost color et
cetera
all the metadata you want um in this in
this json rajasthan so
okay yeah well with that thank you again
so much devin this has been
a delightful talk um thank you everyone
for attending
this concludes our february uh pi data
chicago virtual meetup
we'll be back around this time
last thursday in march for our next one